DAN GILBERT: Well, I have to
say, I feel like the odd man
out here, because
on my left I have
two people who have dedicated
their lives to the publishing
industry.
On my right, I have one of
America's most distinguished
writers.
And I'm a scientist.
I mean, I wrote one book.
I got really lucky.
It became a bestseller.
And I write better than
most scientists do,
which means it's like
being the tallest jockey.
[LAUGHTER]
So I won the lottery,
and everybody thinks
I'm an expert on finance.
But it turns out
that rich people
get to talk about how you
should invest your money,
even if they inherited theirs.
So take this with
a grain of salt.
I ask myself, what
are the things
that I have learned as a result
of the process of writing
my book, that I wish I
had known when I started?
And I thought of three of them.
So the first one is
going to be quite-- I'm
going to be a little contrary.
My observation is that
some people really
want to get married, and so
they go out and find somebody.
And then there are other
people who find somebody,
and it makes them
want to get married.
I think the latter is a
better model for marriage,
and I think it's the right
model for writing a book.
If you're asking yourself, what
should I write a book about,
the answer is nothing.
In other words, you should
be inspired to write a book.
In fact, you should think,
if I don't write this book,
I'm going to continue
to bore everyone
I know by telling
them this thing
that I can't stop thinking
and talking about.
A book should be welling
up inside you to get out.
If you're starting
with, I'd like
to be a writer, that's
the wrong place to start.
Harlan Ellison, a
science fiction writer,
once said, "Anybody who wants
to be an aspiring writer
should ask themselves, if I
couldn't do that, what would
I do?"
And if they can
answer that question,
they should do the other thing.
I think, actually, the
world would be better off
if fewer of us wrote
and more of us read.
There are just a lot of
crummy books out there.
You shouldn't write one.
So if you're
thinking, wouldn't it
be nice to have my
book on a shelf,
and my picture in
the New York Times?
Yeah, that is nice.
But that's not a
reason to write a book.
Passion comes first.
I am constantly reminded of this
because I wrote a bestseller,
which means my agent
and my editor--
at least for a couple of
years-- called every few months
and said, so, what's your
next book going to be about?
To which I replied, I spent
15 years studying one thing,
and I wrote a book about it.
15 years from now, maybe
I'll write another one.
Maybe I'll know something and
be interested in something,
and I'll want to
open my mouth again.
They're stunned by this answer.
Wait a minute, you
have an audience.
Shouldn't you just keep talking?
The answer's no.
They said, well, you could
write that book again.
You could just say it
a little differently.
I said, why do I
want to do that?
So I don't know.
OK.
So point number one
is, probably, you
shouldn't write a book.
Now, assuming that
you are not going
to listen to point number
one, because you came all
the way over here
pretty convinced
that you do want
to write a book,
I would say two things I've
learned about it that I
would like to share with you.
The first is that the main
way in which trade writing, as
far as I can see, differs
from academic writing
is that with academic writing,
or reader naturally shares
our interest,
because we're writing
for people who do what we do.
So when I sit down
to write an article,
I know that the
reader already thinks
that the role of the
ventral medial prefrontal
cortex and temporal discounting
is an earth-shattering topic.
What I have to do is
convince him or her
that what I'm going to say about
it is original and correct.
When a trade reader picks
up a book, first of all,
they don't care if
it's original, as
long as it's original to them.
I have a friend who is a
writer for New York Magazine.
She once asked me, would
you write an article
on x topic for our magazine?
I said, you know, there
was just something
published on that last year.
She said, if it wasn't
published this month,
it was never published.
That's the rule in journalism.
Well, in fact, your
reader has to be stumbling
on your message
for the first time,
but you don't have to be the
first person to ever say it.
Furthermore, you're the expert.
They already trust that
what you're saying is right.
What are they, going to
read my book and go, well,
what does this guy know
about psychological science?
I'm a professor at
Harvard, for God's sakes.
What I have to
convince them about
is the one thing you never
have to convince your audience
about in academics, which
is that what you have to say
is interesting, and important,
and worth listening to.
These are people with options.
OK?
They could be doing something
other than reading your book.
They could be in the bath tub
with macaroons and a party hat.
They could be reading
one of Luke's books.
You have to convince them that
every page should be turned,
and that they are not wasting
their money or their time.
Third, I really think
that readers may not
know what's right.
They may not know
what's original.
But they smell
bullshit a mile away.
They have a nose
for authenticity.
And I think your book-- a good
book is written in your voice.
I had a colleague who once told
me-- after my book came out,
his wife read it.
He said, you know, she came
to me and she said, my god.
Reading this book is like
having a conversation with Dan,
except you don't get to talk
back-- to which, of course,
he said, how is that unlike any
other conversation with Dan?
But I actually took that
as a great compliment--
that, in fact, when
she read my book,
she heard me talking like
I'm talking to you now.
Now, you may think your
academic voice isn't your voice.
You may think your academic
voice is your voice.
It isn't your voice.
You don't go home and talk
to your spouse like that.
If you do, you don't have one at
home, waiting to listen to you.
Right?
You have a real
voice in which you
communicate the things
you care about with people
you care about.
And I think that's the voice in
which you have to write a book,
if you want people to resonate
to what you have to say.
I think along with
that, as we all
laughed when Betsy
said something
about tickling the
public's imagination,
but you know the public.
I think you can't have
contempt for your readers
or, again, once again--
no point in writing.
There are a lot of
people out there
who are every bit as
smart as your students,
and they're more motivated
to hear what you have
to say than your students are.
They really want to learn
what you have to teach them,
and they're smart.
Your job isn't to show them that
you're a little bit smarter.
Your job, as a writer,
is to show them
that they are very
smart, and they
may even have kind of known
what you're telling them,
but couldn't quite put it
into the words you can.
You're sharing a
journey with them.
You're taking them someplace.
You're not leading them
and impressing them.
The one caveat I
would warn you is
that if you do write a book
that sells a lot of copies,
you will be asked to blurb
books for the rest of your life.
So I can only imagine I
get a small smattering
of what Luke does.
But I would say
10 books a week--
somebody sends me and says,
could you say something nice?
I'm at the point
where, basically, I
can't blurb a book-- and
I'm actually saying this,
in case any of you
think you're going
to send me an email-- I can't
blurb a book unless you're
a member of my immediate
family, you've seen me naked,
you've pulled me from a burning
jeep and given me your kidney,
or you're Bob Dylan.
Any of those, I will probably
be able to blurb the book.
Yeah, so there's two errors
you can make in writing.
One is to stop before
you're really finished,
and the other one is to stop
long after you're finished.
So I think I'm going to
err towards the positive
and stop before I'm done.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]